[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je vais commencer par un
rapide rappel des faits comme vous le
savez hier soir lors de l'émission
touche pas à mon poste
cyril hanouna ici présents à disputer un
match de ping pong contre l'animateur de
télévision stéphane plaza en cas de
défaite
cyril s'était engagé à ne pas présenter
l'émission touche pas à mon poste et ce
pendant deux semaines malheureusement
cyril a perdu cette rencontre
nous allons maintenant passer aux
questions est elle donnée au ping pong
magazine est ce que vous allez vous
retirer définitivement du milieu du
tennis de table pour l'instant et aucune
décision qui est prise c'est sûr qu'on
va en parler avec avec les entraîneurs
avec avec le staff que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà je suis pas don
dont j'ai pas de motivation pour aller
faire ou un tennis de table ou un jeu
carrière bilboquet ou autres sports de
balle à proprement parler on voulait
vous montrer donc des gens qui sont un
petit peu stagiaires dans la comédie ce
sont des personnes de touche pas à mon
poste
vous allez devoir les du lait jugé à
riez vous dire vraiment ce que vous
pensez de michel également alors
attention
matthieu delormeau et derrière la porte
vous ouvrez la porte mathieu vous êtes
le patron d'une très grosse société je
vous rappelle vous piquer une colère en
pleine réunion vous ouvrez la porte pour
virer une personne et vous dites je ne
veux pas de ce projet johnson vous êtes
viré sortais de ma chambre
ces partis de leur beau il est où
[ __ ] mais c'est pas possible de me
chier un projet comme ça je monte -
mêmes haircut à une couleur et non le
président du marketing me shittu tout
jeter sortie du caniveau qui tire rien
et maintenant tu es un minable tu as
tout foiré dans cette attente je parle
maintenant c'est toi quatre foires et
s'épanouir et compris pourtant non il me
semble que même michelin équipera ses
brillantes a dû croire x tu vois je t'ai
donné un texte commun
[Rires]
l'impasse qui pour canal+
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pendant
ces deux semaines d'absence du char à
voile normalement je me suis inscrit
dans un stage de char à voile là pendant
deux semaines
mais aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui je
suis dans l'inconnu coup j'ai pris un
gros coup sur la tête
et aujourd'hui il faut que faut que
j'aille de l'avant au matériau je vais
te donner un bon secret pour avoir les
miches bien ferme
il faut les pétrir les yeux fermés et
weeds ou mai
c'est moi attend dé lui c'est les seuls
c'est la seule émission soit est dans la
merde je vous parle parce qu'il ya des
gars le gala c'est la seule émission il
ya des cadreurs mon frère regarder ce
qu'il fait et non mais je vais le
montrer
parce que la région montrer le gars mais
regarde ce qui fait il est comme ça sans
il est comme ça il fait comment on est
la seule émission où les cadeaux
arrivent à se cacher mon frère dont ils
se croient sur tmc dans un documentaire
julien courbet vous êtes un médecin qui
rentre dans la chambre d'une patiente et
lui annonce une terrible nouvelle
je suis désolé madame il va falloir être
forte votre mari n'était autre que
gilles verdez c'est parti oh merde
bonsoir madame je suis le docteur a
encore donné mon retard j'étais chez le
coiffeur mais une terrible nouvelle à
vous annoncer votre mari n'est autre que
gilles verdez c'est bien c'est bien vous
êtes avocat à la cour tout simplement
vous rentrez dans un bureau vous allez
devoir jouer d'une manière dramatique
ces partis ont bien emmerdé votre
honneur mais au calme toi et être au
tribunal avant 15h30
m
[Applaudissements]
il aurait fait peur le gard mais
regardez moi vous avez regardez moi s'il
te plait ça c'est lui le psychopathe par
l'avocat m et 800 m et vous avez une
tête
vous avez terminé dans crime